Wow hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome back to Lakeview
cabin I'm not gonna mess around this
time because I got a guide over here
that's telling me what I need to do in
there is a lot of stuff that you can do
so basically this is going to be the
first achievement run I've ever done
ever ever where are my friends
where's all the other guys oh there you
are okay so the first one is pretty
simple you just have to go over here
somehow I avoided that rake I guess I'm
not the clumsy one get naked wait no the
other person no hang on the other person
has to get naked the other person has to
get naked you have to pick him up
you bring him over here lob him down
there turn that on
and then after that you just have to
drink some beer yep there's still being
chunks up still still waiting for go in
for still getting just gonna get more
drunk well that was fun okay
anyone that was the thing I think I
heard the siren that's another thing
that needs to happen
hello papa shop Oh I expected it to swim
Oh
normal why do I do that
[Music]
okay so anyway there's a lot of
achievements to be made but it takes a
long time to get them and I'm not that
good at this game so I'm just gonna go
and beat the game or at least beat this
one and then you guys will know what I'm
up to here so we're gonna get a little
bit of a fornication going on here if
you know what I mean baby I don't know
why I'm doing baby talk but do you know
moved in Ubud who would you boobsie okay
this weird des is weird yet for
everybody oh this weird okay so we're
gonna go over here what we need to do we
need to oh no wait I need the shotgun
Mac show from in here no can you please
leave leave me alone okay he's gonna
have the guitar cuz he needs a guitar
okay we're gonna have the guitar we're
gonna put the guitar over here so we're
gonna have the guitar go over there
because the guitar is like I discovered
before in the last episode the guitar
actually stuns the first killer and
that's important it's very important
actually so we got the key
understandably we did get the key but
there's another key that you could get
they go to the same place I'm pretty
sure but either way I got this shotgun
shell
but there's another shotgun shell to get
and I'm gonna get that by going up here
over here this the wrong place never
mind going over here going over he'll
pick this up do the same thing we were
doing before nope put that down thank
you this this do a little bit of this
here bang bang bang baby bang okay go
over here this [ __ ] I forgot again god
damnit why do I keep forgetting that as
long as he is alive I guess doesn't
matter cuz he just has to live doink
okay so you're gonna be the guy since
apparently you're not good at anything
else yeah yep yep yep yep yep okay so
now he's got that okay so now you you
are just gonna try to stay safe so you
stay up there with him and hopefully no
one's gonna come murder you okay so now
he is gonna leave this guitar here he's
gonna go get the axe imma Bob and then
the first killer is already gonna start
going out but I need the axe to be
to get another thing that's actually
very important and they need to hide the
sickle from him so because he's gonna
pick up the this here down here is the
sickle and he does not need to pick that
up so I'm gonna go over here I'm gonna
go over here and I'm gonna I'm gonna
actually wait I'm gonna leave this here
and then imma let someone else who has a
shotgun shell put it right there grab
this then I'm gonna use this to break in
- am I breaking in - no not not here not
here yeah I got to be careful
blueberry damn it
oh I know there's gotta be one I know
there's another shotgun shell somewhere
here crap where was it crap crap okay
well I guess we're just gonna go without
it
okey-dokey then I might have to
creatively use something else crap not
what I wanted oh [ __ ] get outta here
wait was it over here yeah who's it all
this was it okay not that what is this
this isn't what I wanted
okay chocolate so exactly what I needed
exactly what I needed there's all the
time left - oh crap
yep okay here we go okay you're gonna be
the shotgun lady you're gonna be the
designated show gunner joke donor donor
away okay so now that I get the
designated show gunner so I can why is
this guy oh that's right not the right
guy okay so you're gonna go here okay I
got the axe I got the I got the axe all
right
yeah acts of fury oh uh first up you
better
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna get popping up
inside Piper's shop you're gonna survive
- just stay up here with them I know I
know it's okay bumpers up it's okay oh
good the eggs hmm I see you in the water
there I see you in the water there I
don't see you come get us some come get
us some is waiting I was gonna get some
hmm
where is he supposed to be here oh I
heard that is that a thing mmm come on
come on come on what you got what you
got
think I don't hear you huh
oh no is that just popping up that's
just poor person up isn't it yeah it's
per person up whoo-hoo here he is okay
he's coming you know what he's coming
okay so I got a bathroom oh come on over
here come on come on you prick oh he
turned out the lights
all right I can fight you in the dark
you think do something you think you
whole lot of hot something you a whole
lotta hot Neilsen nothin there we go
switch it up for the ax and shop Rudy ho
crap okay okay
oh crap oh crap oh crap oh crap oh crap
oh okay well that's not what I wanted
boom you asked for that don't make me do
it again oh okay now we're gonna switch
come on get up get up get up get up
yes you don't know you done oh come on
there's a bunch of baloney Howard's on
the hell all right so I for our
sacrifice of a brick burns there are you
dead yet
you're not dead how are you not dead how
in the hell is he not dead okay we're
gonna try this again
Wow how did he get a corpse strung up
like that already
when were you at which way would you
wear would you wear it will you add oh
it's dead daddy hmm okay I chopped him
up with the ax
now there's another killer one more
killer but I don't know how we're gonna
kill him coming a little bit difficult
much more difficult than I thought it
was gonna be maybe I can burn him alive
the only other chance I got so we're
gonna go for that one we're gonna go for
the hole burning a live deal I'll turn
that back on okay well this guy means
business and by business I mean he sucks
so I gotta burn them farther away
grabbing this there's another match box
over here somewhere if I can't get this
is actually it's gonna be bad no yes it
was got it come on burn burn you burn us
both both burn burn you wanna burn way
to burn razor burn for your sins you
cryin bastard is that cuz I killed your
kid because all these characters are
from the original okay lose a leg here
oh it's worth it worth it worth it
you're gonna burn burn burn for your
sins
ready burn
well maybe I need something nearby
flammable to be able to burn because
there was little logs and stuff well I'm
all right this isn't going as well as I
thought it was gonna go [ __ ] well that's
the whole lot of dead I ain't gonna do
nothing alrighty then he seems mad
mister man wasn't too happy about that
but I can get it you and your friends
are dead but not the puppy the puppy is
still alive and that's where all that
matters okay so I did that wrong with
the first one I was supposed to shave
the shotgun for the other guy and I
think I'm supposed to Blake save the gas
can also because I didn't do that well
either so we're gonna do this again and
this time I'm gonna win okay go go go go
go go go go go go go go go go go no no
no no no on this I might save this for
something put it right there put it
right there
careful bumpers up right here you and me
baby you and me baby you and me baby you
me baby getting that bed okay we're done
thank you thank you for your time okay
you just uh yeah but blue is back on or
something I don't know take that with
you it's over here you uh what AM you
doing clothes back on
no I'm gonna go out this buck-naked cuz
I'm so confident in myself and my
abilities oh crap I forgot I need one
more thing from here
doink doink this please thank you okay
we're gonna do this right and but I do
it right I mean we're not gonna suck
okay over here is I don't even I think
this is like a cooking oil thing maybe
it's flammable I don't know I just need
more bombs along the short of it you do
badoo badoo [ __ ] I forgot I need to get
the guitar we can't leave without the
guitar or poppers or nubs bumper job
don't die
okay so guitar is gonna stay right here
you're gonna stay you're gonna drop that
she's gonna put that there
the other guys got the job go over here
now big guys gonna hold up the thing up
there there we go
okay okay okay hold that
okay you're gonna get this actually
you're gonna put this here you're gonna
get the thanks
you're gonna go get the O's in here oh
[Music]
[Applause]
dammit god dammit oh well I can't get
through anything without being totally
horrible so that's what it is
do hurry alright so the next thing we're
gonna do is I'm gonna be naked and
awesome and you're gonna come up here
popping up because this is not a safe
place for you you're gonna go up here
with the boys you're I'm going to go
down here buck naked cuz I have to be
the hero this damn [ __ ] that means I
only have one shot gunshot okay I have
to do this differently then so I'm gonna
try to do and this is where things get
really dicey so I'm going to try to
light them on fire first we need the
motorcycle that's what we needed we need
the motorcycle we need the motorcycle
baby put the motorcycle right here I
don't know what this does but it's
probably dangerous so we're gonna just
keep that there for now okay you're
saying up there I'm going over here we
do have one shot in the shotty that's
good alright where's this guy he's gonna
get lit he's gonna get lit up by a naked
man how bad does that feel how does that
make you feel actually I'm gonna keep
this here this your bike cuz I'm gonna
blow him up next he's gonna get blown up
maybe I should blow him up first my face
not the time for that Windows Jesus damn
that was effective that was surprisingly
effective that was excessively effective
I should lay my world where more oil
traps then is he still alive probably
still alive
I operate on the assumption they still
alive but he's not happy definitely not
happy or is he maybe he's dead
could that have killed him no if that
could have killed him but not be still
alive okay come over here come over here
over here yeah oh no he's on fire again
what an idiot
what a big dumb idiot good for you okay
so that'll be enough of a deterrent for
now so I'm gonna I'm gonna try to get
through this without we wait where's my
axe where's the axe was the act okay
sickle will do I guess sickle will have
to do I don't know where the axe went
come on
come on get over here hurry up yeah
they're here
come on come on buddy yep
damn it come on what the [ __ ] no no no
no no God you son of a [ __ ] it's okay
just stay down you bastard okay come on
get up
[Music]
no no no no oh crap it's hard like
really hard all right one more
is weird
oh here he goes you're real so I do have
to ring the bell okay that makes more
sense
I guess the bell just shows I'm ready
yeah burn baby burn baby burn baby burn
okay babies are burning so that's good
now I'm gonna clobber him to death with
this frickin guitar were you at Sony Jim
where you at Sunny Boy you gonna run
into the fire again like an idiot come
at me come at me bro
[Music]
again how stupid can you be the answer
is very come on come on come on come on
baby would you baby would you baby
come on point that's right oh no the
poor baby I don't care
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah
[Music]
that's right that's right come on come
on
that's right this is how we do this is
how we do is that we do in my
neighborhood nope thank
[ __ ] oh [ __ ]
oh no he's gonna pick up the axe oh no
[Music]
okay
shouldn't need much more shouldn't need
much more
on how much more do you need is
ridiculous it's for goddamn dig ulis how
tough can this baby be oh ok well never
mind then ok jeez stay down
oh crap no no no no no no no sorry Mike
no God oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh god damn it
Oh in a split second everything goes
wrong always got a frickin axe - god
damn it
all right fine you want you want a mess
bang
criminy Christmas just stay dead it's
amazing
will not stay down will not stay down
[Music]
almost go gotta be close he's gotta be
close oh no no no no no no no no no no
no all right fine it's all I got
they've ever been final okay well now
I'm just kind of screwed for the other
guy because I don't think the guitar
makes him stop how did he string up that
body
uh well tits
Oh God just [ __ ] die already a piece
of [ __ ] oh god damn it
all right we're gonna do this we're all
really real have a face full of is he
dead I did it I think I did I think I
did it and now I go over here oh I
[Music]
basket naked for this is ceremonial yay
I'll get my friend to join me a real
quick whoa hey I'm a hobbling as fast as
I can
friend ooh be right there in no time
anybody
okay
I can make it - hello was I supposed to
bring a weapon it's pretty song but I'm
not sure what I'm just uh around I'll be
right back as soon as I get a weapon
good thing everyone else seems to be
extremely excessively dead I wouldn't
have wanted to finish this adventure
with him
there was a flare gun over here we just
make sure this guy's nice and dead I
just want to make sure maybe I could in
case of emergency break glass I'm pretty
sure that's what this is all about
yep this seems like an emergent system
uh well I didn't work at least I got
some cold brewskies if I throw some
underwear you know what do I do
am I supposed to do okay okay so I was
on the right track I just have a long
way to go before I get to the right
track so I gotta go around I was in the
right position I just didn't have the
right weapon oh yeah I got this so I
have to finish this as median as bloody
as I may be I'm ready to finish this and
get to the end you hill as my friends
died as my family died as my great big
orgy partner died so too shall you
wha-wha-wha wha-wha-wha-wha get ready
are you ready for the end because I no
no no no no no where to go where my ass
go
what the hell what the hell what the
hell happened what the hell happened
what no no this better not screw me over
this better not screw me over because I
will be very upset I've been trying this
for a long time now and it better do it
good cuz if it don't I will be very
upset la la la la la I know yes I know
[Music]
am I gonna I [ __ ] drop it are you
kidding me are you kidding me oh come on
what the hell oh god you suck
okay all right cool both Gokul now we're
gonna try to lure him underneath here
get ready on that come on where is he
[Music]
no way he's dead no way he's dead oh
he's dead holy crap kid [ __ ] you [ __ ]
okay no I just got to get in position I
don't think the sirens there yet that's
her name the siren
ding dissonance dissonance dissonance oh
my goodness how babies are to kill
I keep getting screwed up because like
on the control stick it's so easy to
flip your character around without even
trying there you are get ready you ready
you ready don't care don't even care
don't even care yeah there we go there
we go whoa
that's the original guy from the first
Lakeview cabin and Mary oh it took me a
long long time to get that done but I
got it done I didn't go through as many
achievements as I wanted to mostly just
cuz that took a lot of time so anyway
thank you everybody so much for watching
there's still another part of this game
to be done
Lake View cabin part 4 and I may just go
through the walkthrough from the
beginning there because really gotta be
very specific and very patient which I'm
not so thank you everybody so much for
watching I really hope you enjoyed this
one if you did let me know in the
comments below thank you again and as
always I will see
in the next video
[Music]